buongiorno
in effetti io non ho preparato niente e
non solo un video e raccontarvi un po
degli incroci nella mia vita ho vissuto
un sacco di incroci come penso per voi è
la vera differenza la fa la decisione
che prendi all'incrocio
se andare a destra se andare a sinistra
se andare sopra se andare sotto e in
effetti poi mi sono accorto che
l'innovazione nasce proprio degli
incroci innovazione vuol solo dire fare
qualcosa che gli altri non fanno poter
dire solo io
16 anch'io vuol dire che non sei un
innovatore vuol dire che sia uno che
segue qualcos'altro
e poi quando arrivi alla fine della vita
il poter dire il solo io ciascuno di noi
lo potere perché la nostra vita non è
uguale a quella di nessun altro e quindi
vi volevo portare un pò in questo
racconto molto veloce di quelli che sono
gli incroci che secondo me fanno un po
la differenza non c'è niente di giusto
non c'è niente di sbagliato sono solo
opinioni personali
dopo tanti anni di vita è l'unica cosa
che faccio ancora che quella che va
accompagnato tutta la vita e quello che
ha detto lui e fare il dj
lo faccio ancora sabato sera le feste
anzi mi diverto moltissimo ma devo dire
che fare il dj mi ha insegnato
tantissimo mi ha insegnato nel capire le
persone mi ha insegnato come tenere un
palco mi ha insegnato anche a capire
quello che le stesse persone non
capiscono e quindi ho preparato un video
che dura solo 4 minuti durante il video
vi racconto un po gli incroci che
troverete in questo video ve li premetto
c'è un primo incrocio che quello tra
territorio tecnologia e persone partiamo
col video il video parte molto
semplicemente con quelle che sono le il
mio territorio dove io sono cresciuto è
una valle si chiama valle del cielo e ed
è un fiume il cielo è un fiume dove mio
padre faceva il mugnaio e dove io ho
cominciato a fare il mugnaio con mio
papà perché la prima cosa che mi ha
insegnato è che la scuola non è un
diritto ma te le devi guadagnare questa
è la lamborghini miura la prima macchina
che ha progettato all'ingegner dall'ara
un incrocio straordinario che ho avuto
e qui vedete il mio paese dove vivo io
bardi in provincia di parma
questo è il castello di bardi e questa è
la strada che faccio io e tutte le
mattine per andare a lavorare
sono ventuno minuti 22 se c'è traffico
si arriva alla dallara e qui vedete
questo incrocio straordinario e che ho
fatto negli anni 2000 con l'ingegner
dall'ara un altro grandissimo innovatore
un personaggio veramente da cui ho
imparato tantissimo e questa è la
dallara un'azienda che fa macchine da
corsa
noi siamo sotto traccia non ci vedete
molto anche se siamo il più grande
produttore al mondo di macchine da corsa
commerciali qui vedete due macchine in
pista sono due piste completamente
diverse
un e varano de melegari in provincia di
parma un posto grosso così
l'altra è la pista di indianapolis dove
anche quest'anno abbiamo vinto la 500
miglia di indianapolis
la gara più importante al mondo ecco
questo è come noi lavoriamo cosa trovate
dentro la nostra azienda
vedete qui tecnologie e questa è la
fibra di carbonio che utilizziamo per
costruire le nostre macchine
corsa vedete persone grandissima
artigiane che hanno una capacità manuale
e persone che lavorano insieme
la prima cosa che capisci quando l'ente
in un'azienda come queste che una
persona da sola per quanto sia brava una
macchina non lo può costruire deve
lavorare con le competenze degli altri
qui vedete quello che è la competition
ha subito dynamics dove studiamo il
movimento dei del dell'area su un corpo
qui vedete i modelli che vanno in
galleria del vento
questo è un modello della macchina che
corre a indianapolis e anche questo è un
incrocio quando fai una macchina da
corsa deve incrociare aerodinamica
dinamica del veicolo leggerezza messi
insieme un motore ti permette di vincere
o perdere una gara magari per un
centesimo di secondo
questa è la galleria del vento dove
viene provata la macchina è una replica
di quello che è la realtà
e qui vedete un altro oggetto
straordinario di cui parlerò un attimo
più approfonditamente che è un
simulatore di guida è un oggetto che si
muove di 8 metri nello spazio con dentro
un pilota e permette a un pilota di
guidare una macchina che non è mai stata
costruita guida solo modelli matematici
perché ricordatevi che l'innovazione
nasce dall errore più possibilità di
sbagliare più divento innovativo e qui
abbiamo costruito una meravigliosa
macchina per sbagliare a basso costo
il pilota prova anche delle idee più
strampalate e poi ci dice se va bene
meno quindi avete visto territorio
tecnologia e questo è l'ultimo incrocio
è la vittoria alla 500 miglia di
indianapolis
l'abbiamo vinta 15 volte in 100 anni
siamo l'azienda che l'ha vinta più volte
e qui è il motivo per cui l'abbiamo
vinta sono queste persone qua sono
queste persone che sono dietro questa
vittoria è un piccolo gruppo di persone
ma sono le persone che fanno la
differenza
un'azienda e straordinaria perché è
fatta da persone straordinarie e quindi
quando uno fa il capo azienda deve saper
incrociare queste tre cose il suo
territorio
la tecnologia le persone e questo
incrocio è molto importante perché in un
mondo globale dove ci troviamo noi oggi
la vera competizione non è più tra le
singole aziende ma è tra sistemi
territoriali
quindi non è importante che l'azienda
sia competitiva perché se competitiva in
un territorio che non è competitivo è
destinato a fallire
quindi tutti noi imprenditori dobbiamo
fare qualcosa per fare in modo che il
nostro territorio diventi competitivo e
questa competizione permetta il nostro
territorio di vincere nel mondo noi ci
troviamo nella motor valley
all'inizio della motor valley c'è la
dallara
alla fine c'è la toro rosso
faenza siamo nell'appennino nel raggio
di 150 km trovate dall'ara pagani
laborghini alfa romeo maserati ferrari
ducati toro rosso perché siamo tutti lì
la nostra forza e territorio perché ci
sono degli artigiani fantastici che
servono tutti noi
c'è chi sa fare la limatura e magari non
sapete neanche cos'è ed è un'azienda di
15 persone fantastiche c'è un'azienda
invece di 20 persone fantastiche che fa
la lappatura sono due cose completamente
diverse
e questo territorio rinasce solo se noi
insieme cominciamo a costruire il nostro
futuro e vi racconto come un piccolo
esperimento che abbiamo cominciato ad
incrociare incrociare l'azienda con la
scuola un parto difficilissimo ma
mettendoci insieme lavorando insieme mi
ricordo la preside quando l'ho
incontrata mi diceva i ragazzi di oggi
non vogliono più studiare
noi siamo in un piccolo paesino e
vogliono tutti andare nel istituto
tecnico in città e perdiamo il 30 per
cento di iscritti ogni anno quindi fra
cinque anni noi chiudiamo e della mia
scuola la scuola che dà forza al mio
territorio
allora li abbiamo discusso e gli ho
detto guarda cominciano a pensare che il
problema il nostro non è dei ragazzi ve
la faccio breve in negli ultimi due anni
le iscrizioni in due anni sono aumentate
del 300 per cento
adesso i ragazzi vengono da tutta italia
studiare lì abbiamo preso 200 ormai sono
quasi 200 disoccupati del nostro
territorio abbia messo i nostri
ingegneri affari della formazione altro
incrocio fantastico e magicamente queste
200 persone oggi lavorano
quindi le persone sono le stesse
il territorio e lo stesso quello che è
cambiato è quello che sanno
ecco se noi siamo capaci di incrociarci
e di mettere ciascuno di noi le proprie
competenze le proprie esperienze per
costruire un futuro dove voler stare
tutti noi abbiamo in particolare i
nostri politici che ci descrivono un
futuro dove non vogliamo stare e poi si
lamentano che non votiamo
allora forse tra tra di noi a trovarci
insieme e provare a ragionare su come
costruire il futuro del nostro
territorio del nostro paese e io penso
che abbiamo delle opportunità
straordinarie
però questo incrocio dell'appennino del
dove io sono cresciute dove adesso sono
ritornato perché ho avuto la fortuna di
avere una grandissima azienda come ibm
che mi ha preparato per 27 anni per fare
il mestiere che faccio oggi cioè il
creatore di futuro io la responsabilità
che mi sento quando tu diventi
imprenditore non è quella di guadagnare
soldi i soldi servono ma quando ne hai
abbastanza va bene ma è quello di
costruire un futuro quando tu hai un
azienda la vedi come un figlio ciascuno
di noi quando un figlio non pensa a
quanto guadagno ma che cosa sto facendo
per creare un futuro mio figlio
quali sono i puntoni che sto costruendo
ecco per far questo io ho usato un'altra
metafora
che va dal territorio e vado sul no non
partiamo col video per piacere
su questo oggetto che il simulatore di
guida
questo è un oggetto che tutti i nostri
progettisti anche all'esterno ci
dicevano che era impossibile da fare
cioè far guidare a un umano dei modelli
matematici e noi cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo assunto 14 neo laureati loro non
sapevano che era impossibile l'hanno
fatto
funziona talmente bene che ne abbiamo
fatto uno anche indianapolis negli stati
uniti
però questo incrocio che ho messo nel
mio titolo tra velocità la velocità con
cui accadono le cose c'è un terremoto a
fukushima e la general motors in america
non consegna più auto perché il chip
dell'airbag lo facevano la e questo
succede in tempo reale cade la borsa di
tokyo o ripercussione in america dopo
due minuti quindi alla velocità con cui
accadono le cose
combinato con un altro fattore è
l'incertezza
io non so cosa succederà fra cinque
minuti e quello che succederà non è
prevedibile il terremoto che è successo
non lo potevo prevedere come non posso
capire se succederà una cosa piuttosto
che un'altra con le previsioni quindi
cosa devo fare devo preparare la mia
azienda al mio lavoro a gestire queste
due cose velocità e incertezza che
combinate matematica si chiamano caos
ecco la grande e bella notizia per noi è
che noi italiani siamo maestri nel
gestire caos
a noi chiaramente non ci batte nessuno
guarda te lo dico seriamente se voi dite
un americano guarda guarda per uscire
devi aprire quella porta
se la porta è aperta l'americano non
esce perché l'istruzione per uscire aprì
le porte
l'italiano non ci pensa neanche esce
guardate che questa è una competenza è
un modo di essere che dato dalla nostra
cultura variegata noi facciamo 16
materiale scuole medie ne facciamo 18
alle superiori facciamo le università
con 30 40 esami vuol dire apertura
mentale culturale però le nostre imprese
quindi devono essere preparate a gestire
questi due fattori e vi lascio con
l'ultimo punto che l'incrocio tra
preparato e pronto
noi non possiamo più pensare di essere
pronti a gestire il cambiamento perché
pronto implica due cose 1 che so che
cosa succede 2 quando io sono pronto per
andare a cena questa sera alle 8 quindi
noi dobbiamo costruire delle aziende
preparate e questo vuol dire che anche
noi come persone dobbiamo prepararci a
gestire un futuro che stanno e disegnare
e anche partecipare a questi eventi dove
si mischia musica tecnologia idee è un
modo per prepararsi a gestire il futuro
e ricordiamoci dipende solo da noi
grazie